where I left off in the last video we
saw if we had a magnetic field coming in
from the right and we had this loop of
of I guess we called metal or a circuit
and it's carrying a current in this
where the current is coming in this
direction you can imagine positive
protons although we know the electrons
go in the other direction but the
current is coming in this direction and
going out that direction we figured out
using the right-hand rule and just this
formula that the net force of the
magnetic field coming in this direction
on this arm of the wire or the circuit
is net downwards right and on this arm
it was net upwards and so it provided a
net torque on this circuit or as I said
in the last video a paperclip and where
this dotted line is the axis of rotation
then this is how I showed you it would
rotate right where the the magnetic
field is essentially pushing up on the
right-hand side and pushing down on the
left-hand side it has no effect over
here on the top and the bottom so it
would rotate in this direction and then
this was a kind of what it looks like
after it rotates a little bit and what I
though the whole reason why I did that I
said well this arm which is the same as
this arm the net force is still upwards
out of our screen but that upwards
direction is now no longer going to be
completely perpendicular to the moment
arm distance that's the moment arm
distance now the moment arm distance is
kind of coming at an angle out of the
page so only some of this net outward
force from the magnetic field is going
to be perpendicular perpendicular to the
moment arm and so the torque on it will
be less but it's still going to be
torque in that same direction kind of
coming out of the page on the right and
into the page on the left and the same
is true of the left hand side and then
you go all the way to the point that the
coil is actually vertical where this
side this side right here is on top and
this side is on bottom below the plane
of your video screen and at that point
the torques actually there there is no
net torque and why is that because on
this top part when it's pointing
straight out at you when it's right here
the magnetic field the the force of it
the force that it's affecting the the
circuit is pushing straight up so
there's no longer any net torque right
because the force is pushing straight up
and that moment arm distance this
distance is now also pointing point
straight up and torque is also a cross
product so you actually care about the
perpendicular forces so there at this
vertical point there is no net torque
and the same is true at the bottom of
the of the circuit because at the bottom
the magnetic field force is going to be
downwards which is parallel with the
moment arm distance so there's no net
torque and I said well maybe there's a
little bit of of angular momentum that
keeps the this object rotating and then
it will rotate too and let me and this
is where it gets interesting I'll draw
it neatly then it'll rotate to this
point once again I want to have the
perspective its perspective will rotate
here so let me just make sure I have all
so here it was rotating in this
direction and in that direction right
and then here maybe some that there's no
longer any torque on it but it still
might on the top be moving to the left
and on the bottom moving to the right up
to a point that it's going to get into
this configuration where this this side
is so it's rotated at this point it has
rotated more than 90 degrees so this
edge is now this edge it had rotated
from here all the way it's still
pointing out of the screen but if this
edge is the same as this edge now this
the current direction is going to be
like this right because this Edge has
rotated down also it's rotated from that
position all the way to the back to this
position so the current is now coming
let me make sure let me draw it on the
right the current is coming like that
like that like that going up here and to
the right up like that right so the
current now on this left hand side
although it was the former right hand
side it's still going in that upwards
direction so when you take the cross
product what is going to be the net
magnetic field on that
or the force of the magnetic field well
you do this you do the same right hand
rule point your index finger up put your
middle finger in the direction of the
magnetic field this is the palm this is
your other two fingers let me draw the
fingernails just so they're painted
fingernails not that mine are then your
thumb points upwards so on this side of
the coil
we still have an upwards force and if
you do the cross-product where you do
the right-hand rule on the on the bottom
side or the behind side you could have
even imagined it you're still going to
have a net downward force so now all of
a sudden you could imagine the thing had
rotated so it had rotated in the way I
drew it here where it pops out on this
side and it goes in on that side and it
had done it all the way to the point
where we had rotated more than 90
degrees but now all of a sudden the net
force through the magnetic field is
going to reverse right because the side
that has the current going upwards is
now the left-hand side so now the force
from the magnet field is out on this
side and you're going to you're going to
want to rotate in the opposite direction
hopefully that makes sense just think
about what happens visualize this coil
rotating so what is essentially going to
happen is you're going to rotate you're
going to rotate like I did here on the
top maybe once you get to this level
you're going to have a little bit of
angular momentum that will keep you
rotating or rotational inertia that'll
keep you rotating until you're in
something like this configuration maybe
you go all the way back to this
configuration where the sotware it's
essentially a complete 180-degree turn
right and then B then since on this side
the current is going to be going up and
on this side the currents going down
because you've essentially flipped this
thing over then the effect of magnetic
field is going to say well upwards on
the Left downwards on the right right
and so it's going to turn the other way
so if you think about it it's going to
keep oscillating let me draw it from let
me draw it from a well I don't want to
drop from that hang because I want to
confuse you so we have a problem if we
wanted to turn this into some type of
electric motor and keep it spinning we
would either have to reverse the current
once you get into this configuration or
either turn off the magnetic field or
maybe you could reverse the magnetic
field to get it going in the other
direction and actually you have another
problem which is a slightly lesser
problem is this if this was a circuit
you just kept turning over and over the
circuit the wires would get twisted here
so you couldn't do it indefinitely so
the solution here is something called a
commutator a commutator so let me draw a
commutator so what if let me I have
let's see the same same circuit which I
have now drawn Messier but it has these
two leads has these leads that
essentially curve you can imagine them
curving out of the page and then we have
a circuit it can you can imagine leads
here to and there this this round thing
and this thing or they're touching each
other the whole time so current could
pass through it right let me draw my
battery this is positive and this is
negative so up here on the circuit the
current is always going to be flowing in
this direction it's always going to be
flowing in this direction it's always
going to be flowing up and like this
right now when you're in this
configuration what's going to happen
well the current is going to flow down
here that's going to be I and that's
going to be I and when you do your
right-hand rule we have the same
magnetic field I haven't changed the
magnetic field coming in from the left
so just like we did before I cleared the
screen you use the right-hand rule and
you'll figure out well the net force
from the magnetic field is going to be
upwards here and downwards here and
that's what's going to create that net
torque and you're going to rotate this
part so this part of this contraption is
going to rotate you could imagine maybe
there's like a little pole here maybe
it's a non-conducting Pole so that none
of the you know and it can it's
connected to an axle somewhere so you
can rotate along
taxes right so the force of the magnetic
field is going to create a torque we're
going to rotate up on this side up out
of the page on that side and into the
page on that side and then behind the
page and then back out of the page right
that's what the net for torque would be
and then we would get it and it would
keep doing that until you get to the
vertical configuration so so at the
vertical configuration this is the
circuit on the top stays exactly the
same so the vertical configuration and
I'm trying my best to draw this properly
at the vertical configuration one of two
things can happen and probably the best
thing is is that we actually lose
contact with the two leads
so maybe the SIRT the actual current
stops flowing when we're in the vertical
configuration I'll do it in the same
color so when we're vertical we just see
you know the top we see this and then we
see you know it pops out a little bit
and then we see this arm right there and
then we see that pole that's maybe
holding it or that it's helping it
rotate all right but we're still having
some a you know the current has seized
so there's not going to be any torque no
force through the magnetic field because
we've lost touch at that point right
because these things kind of point out
hopefully you kind of you you you you
could visualize how to build such a
thing and we're still rotating in this
direction because of some type of
rotational inertia then this is what the
interesting part is what happens when we
rotate more than ninety degrees and I
just realized that I'm pushing over ten
minutes so you can think about that a
little bit while I stop here and
continue this in the next video see you
soon